il aime budget si alec castonguay
christian duffau bonsoir vous asseoir je
suis au tout les trucs d'eau sont au
québec ce soir
monsieur au tour avec grenier journée et
monsieur
trudeau était avec jean chrétien hier en
ontario on écoute un petit extrait de
monsieur chrétien puis on revient
j'ai été quelque peu froissé comme le
1er mai nice car
le chef du bloc a prétendu que c'est lui
qui parlait au nom de
tous les québécois
et puis j'étais lit pendant 40 ans au
québec
j'ai jamais eu personne je parlais à mon
nom est aujourd'hui
il a prétendu qu'il parlait au nom des
acadiens et bien les acadiens millions
d'e-mails toi tes affaires on est
capable de parler pour nous mêmes
ce chrétien rendez vous au service dit à
monsieur trudeau quand on parle de
langue de se mêler de ses affaires dit à
valeurs québécoises de se mêler de ses
affaires vous êtes un monsieur trudeau
quand on parle de gestion du système de
santé au québec de semer liszt à faire
dit à monsieur trudeau quand on parle de
financement des infrastructures
municipales au québec de se mêler de ses
affaires et si ça arrive je vois faire
un effort
alors hélène vous avez revu monsieur
chrétien hier comme nous tous en
campagne d'abord ce que ça vous a étonné
est-ce que vos premières réactions et on
parle d après moi ce qui m'étonne c'est
ce que je m'apprête à vous dire patrice
sais que mon dieu je m'en suis ennuyé de
monsieur chrétien
ou
cette façon candide de parler de parler
de son car on est d'accord ou pas avec
ce qu'il dit mais on sent vraiment qu'il
parle avec passion qu'il n'a pas besoin
d'un script et de petites lignes
préétabli mon dieu que ça manquait dans
cette campagne électorale et suis pas la
seule c'est une tendance qui s'était
établi depuis un certain temps mais on
n'a pas de cette passion de cette
sincérité cette authenticité lot de la
part des chefs politiques et je trouve
que monsieur monsieur la tv nous
rappeler sur la bonne vieille façon de
faire la politique de dire s'il
sera pas d'amis partout mais ceux qui
pensent comme lui au moins vont dire
voilà voilà ils voteront exactement ils
vont ils vont pouvoir connecter avec lui
monsieur chrétien il est très populaire
encore dans plein d'endroits au canada
donc c'est sûr que ça fait quelques pas
parmi eux qu'ont leur sort comme ça la
toute fin mais je pense que ça fait
toujours encore son effet pour les
libéraux alec
oui ça rappelle en fait les belles âmes
ige parti libéral 3 mandat majoritaire
consécutif l'époque beaucoup de premiers
ministres qui sont capables de de se
vanter d'avoir ce bilan la ln raison
selon le genre depuis maintenant
quelques campagnes électorales le bo est
rendu à 87 ans jean chrétien visiblement
il aime encore la politique au moins
pour faire un rassemblement par année et
vous savez on et puis on va parler de
wayne rooney ou si lors d'une campagne
électorale où
on est surtout seulement en train de
motiver sa base à sortir boîte et de
deux grands types de campagnes
électorales celle où on persuade les
gens d'aller voter pour nous même s'ils
ne sont pas des sympathisants naturel
c'est un peu les campagnes par exemple
en 2015 que justin trudeau avait été
mené on a des gros taux de participation
quand on s'attend à des taux de
participation faible c'est l'autre type
de campagne qu'on mène campagne de
motivation aller chercher sa base au
moins que ceux qui veulent voter pour
vous sorte et ça c'est très important
jean chrétien jour sept sur sept corps
de l'heure pour les libéraux ryan malone
et le fait au québec on en parlera
peut-être un peu moins ailleurs au pays
mais au québec certainement que ça
paiera moins d'effets dont on est
actuellement mal ralliement des
troupes s'il faut sortir voter parce que
ça va être serré christian sait on sent
pas monsieur chrétien pour convaincre
des conservateurs on sort monsieur
chrétien pour convaincre des libéraux
peut-être nous qui seraient restés chez
eux d'aller voter
oui qui rappelle des bons vieux
souvenirs libéraux ont pour revenir sur
ce que dit elle c'est vrai que monsieur
chrétien c'est une nature et sur tout un
contraste avec des interventions
totalement script et de justin trudeau
ou défendant l'impression que c'est un
robot choisi je pense ferait quand même
parle un peu du contenu de ce que dit
monsieur qu'est ce qui est intéressant
il tente est en fait la prétention du
bloc québécois ou de monsieur legault de
parler au nom de l'ensemble des
québécois c'est je ne pas faire un lien
avec l'intervention de gabriel da goudjo
après-midi un chant qui contestaient
monsieur truc monsieur legault un peu la
même façon dans le chef des nations mais
il ya aussi autre chose donc le contenu
d'intervention de monsieur qui était
pour sentais que ça venait du coeur en
tactile nous les gens du fédéral on a
quand même une justice certaine
légitimité ou ça va représenter le
québec s'y font mine à l'aps dans le
débat dont un petit mot son bras dans la
journée vous les médias avec au québec
il grand respect pour monsieur la
journée etc il ya des coins au pays où
il allume pas le même le même sourire
chez les gens alors que penser de cette
sortie mais on va commencer avec vous
christian tour de table rapide bah moi
je te souhaite beaucoup plus important
que l'intervention de monsieur chrétien
qui était dans la nature des choses dans
lequel monsieur mulroney souvenons nous
que dans le passé le carré m'appuie
monsieur trudeau pour lequel il avait
comme une certaine tendresse et monsieur
mulroney ont dit tout le temps était
populaire impôt populaire dans le reste
du canada mais le temps a passé et c'est
clair comme monsieur mulroney incarne
une modération très très très profond
c'est un prévis historiques du canada
donc c'est un très beau cadeau qu'il
fallait rhino toul et au nouveau parti
conservateur dans l'une des
vulnérabilités c'est kandia c'est un peu
un puits sont influencés par les états
unis puis si radicale monsieur mulroney
ce n'est pas un radical c'est un
progressiste conservateur et c'est la
première fois qu'ils sortent pour
appuyer qu'avec le nouveau parti kwa
savatan donc je trouve que c'est plus
important que monsieur chrétien
c'est comme s'ils allaient qu'hélène il
disait mais surtout vous avez les yeux
en tout cas réussi le recentrage du
parti allait
suffisamment au moins pour s'afficher à
ses côtés jamais brno rooney aurait été
un rassemblement donc ça montre quand
même qu'il ya une bonne différence entre
les deux hommes je suis persuadé que de
la rivière des outaouais jusque dans
l'est du pays de de ralliement à l'eau
vont être bien reçu parce que les
progressistes-conservateurs les ouverte
au rize aime beaucoup de mal au nez
c'est vrai au québec chaire est dans les
provinces atlantiques en général
gouvernement conservateur à partir de la
rivière des outaouais que dans l'ouest
il faut juste en alberta en saskatchewan
en ontario aussi en colombie britannique
où si le message va être un peu
différent peut-être que celui qui ces
demandes là où sans avoir une auto avec
qui son recentrage pour dire est ce
qu'on voit un peu trop loin
[Musique]
est ce que c'est oui qu'est ce que j'en
pensais la moi je pense que c'est un jeu
dangereux que je joue monsieur otto avec
ceux du fait que ça arrive si
tardivement dans la campagne d'abord
c'est au québec qu'on le sort monsieur
mulroney parce que comme mes collègues
l'ont dit c'est là qu'il est le plus
populaire mais écoutez quand on regarde
les chiffres les intentions vote au
québec airpod raz-de-marée conservateurs
ils sont plus ou moins 18% d'intentions
de vote réalistement les conservateurs
peuvent aller chercher peut-être 1 à 3
sièges de beauport
trois rivières dont alors ce que ça peut
seulement faire c'est augmenter juste
assez les votes conservateurs pour venir
siphonner ceux du bloc québécois et
faire gagner des libéraux donc
globalement à l'échelle nationale pour
monsieur où tout le saviez aussi la
barre qu'il doit dépasser pour avoir
plus de sièges que les libéraux et
aspirer à former le gouvernement donc
d'un point de vue stratégie je suis pas
certaine que ce soit gagnant et comme le
disent mes collègues dans le reste du
pays il n'est pas si populaire et cette
idée le fils vient confirmer un
recentrage me semble que ça aurait dû
arriver bien avant
cette sortie le monsieur au tour
aujourd'hui dire c'est un nouveau parti
conservateur écouter on est à cinq jours
du vote il me semble que ça fait cinq
mois qu'il aurait dû dire ça donc ça
sonne un peu factice collé à la dernière
minute je pense à tout ça marche une
semaine plus tard un peu moins d'une
semaine parce que le débat était jeudi
dernier la question de la modératrice
qui a fait un amalgame entre la loi 21
la loi pour la protection du français
la discrimination le racisme et s'est
fait encore jaser je vous fais entendre
les chefs on vient
je trouve que la prémisse de la question
était inacceptable et je pense que ce
serait important que le consortium
s'explique et s'excuse
les québécois sont pas racistes je suis
tanné de le québec pêche et le
consortium doit s'excuser comme j'ai dit
la question était injuste rien à voir
dans la question on le subit on l'a pas
demandé ce n'est pas un cadeau c'est une
révélation c'est une porte qui s'ouvre
sur la réalité de commun le canada
perçoit le québec monsieur blanchet qui
se faisait poser la question je vous
avez reçu un cadeau extraordinaire c'est
pas un cadeau vous venez de l'entendre
c'est une révélation il est ce que
c'était comme un turbo sur son moteur
parce que là il ya trois quatre points
de plus pour le blog converse au cours
des prochains jours alors où vous en
êtes une semaine plus tard hélène
mai puis il y en aura pas d'excusés le
consortium l'a assez dit clairement il
aurait serré à vielle déclaration vous
savez c'est effectivement une révélation
rappelez-vous qu'en 2019 au débat des
chefs en anglais il y avait une question
sur la loi 21 qui avait hérité aussi
présenté comme quelque chose de
discriminatoire la journaliste qui avait
posé cette question avait été critiqué
et donc on savait le à quoi on
s'attendait et le fait que la rétro des
excuses et moyens pour être honnête
althiar âge n'avait pas fait l'amalgamé
avec la défense de france
lol la question la modératrice qui
apprenaient bouge beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'éléments et il y avait un
amalgame qui était douteux là mais je
ferme ma part seulement vous avez raison
mais à la 2019 y avait pas encore la loi
96 c'est vrai que l'ajout du mot racisme
est venu à mettre une couche ce que je
veux quand même dire c'est que c'est pas
comme si on s'attendait pas du tout à ce
que des réactions y avait un sondage ce
matin d'une logique que j'ai trouvé
vraiment très révélateur on va opposer
les questions est-ce que vous pensez que
le français est menacé au canada au
québec 73 % des gens ont dit oui dans le
reste du pays 73% des gens qu'on dit non
alors il ya aussi ce décalage l'autre
fait que dans le canada anglais on
comprend pas ses velléités québécoise
lot de vouloir protéger le français
parce qu'on le ressent pas la réalité de
la même façon conclusion alec et
christian là dessus parce que je veux
parler de la passe d'armes qu'un au
salon bleu alec
on y les variations sur un même thème
aujourd'hui là il n'y a pas beaucoup de
nouveautés des journaux tout juste
d'être doivent ai dit que la question
était injuste et inappropriée
on a ajouté les excuses mais on ça fait
plusieurs jours le qui a pas beaucoup de
nouveauté dans ce débat là parce que le
dommage on a été fait de bien ceux qui
veulent voter en fonction de cette
question là ceux qui veulent punir la
modératrice là où le reste du canada
jusqu'au 6 et modératrice vraiment le
reste du canada mais ceux qui veulent le
faire vont l'avoir fait pour évasion
peut-être
qu'il faut uniquement sur cette question
je
pense que c'est un tournant dans la
campagne qui donne beaucoup d'énergie au
bloc québécois pour peut pas exclure des
succès bloqué ce plus important qu'on le
prévoit malheureusement ce n'est pas un
accident c'est ce que question le ca
révèle quelque chose de très profond en
fait que j'avais été réglé dans le vieux
contentieux québec canada le canada
comme si un politique qui est disposé à
célébrer toutes les identités de la
galaxie sauf la québécoise et un mépris
par intermittence pour le québec depuis
les débuts ce qu'avait fait quelque
chose qu'on ne peut pas régler tous
qu'on a beaucoup focalisé sur la
souhaiter la souveraineté mais sans le
jamais réglé de quelque chose qui vient
la conquête qui est encore là il ressort
à intervalles réguliers c'est très
profond c'est pas minard donc c'est pas
étonnant si c'est un épais fait sur la
campagne jusqu'à quel point on le verra
mais moi ce que je trouve super bike est
intéressante parce qu'on est pendant le
super ciel puis tout peut changer
jusqu'à la fin on le sait les
altérations voilà t-il dans les deux
trois jours ça peut encore évoluer très
bien où je vous fais entendre donc on en
parle vous est fait référence à
christian ce tout à l'heure à la au
salon bleu de l'assemblée nationale le
premier ministre et le chef de québec
solidaire
depuis quelques jours le premier
ministre au secours b à l'un de ses
pires défauts s'est mis à faire sa
meilleure imitation de maurice duplessis
il s'est autoproclamé père de la nation
québécoise le chef de québec solidaire
nous parle de maurice duplessis
j'avais beaucoup de défauts mais il
défend des sa nation il y était pas un
rock comme le chef de québec solidaire
et ça s'est poursuivi comme ça la suite
le moelleux jouer à touche pas ma
compétence avec ottawa honnêtement ça
m'intéresse pas tant que ça nous notre
ambition pour le québec on veut faire un
pays avec des infirmières dans les
écoles les emplois verts partout sur le
territoire le show vient de sortir du
sac
on a tous bien entendu le chef
parlementaire québec solidaire que d'y
défendre les compétences du québec face
à ottawa ça ne m'intéresse pas
ça veut dire qu'on attend un référendum
sur la souveraineté
alec vous êtes là
pour seulement cela veut dire wang s'est
éveillée en anglais si c'est les gens
éveillés à tout ce qui est justice
raciste elle société et c'est devenu un
terme qu'on utilise donc des gens qui ne
voient à peu près que chars pour ceux
qui l'utilisent négativement à l'est
c'est quand on voit le prisme des
inégalités sociales et de la
discrimination d'abord par identité et
non pas par la classe sociale donc je
sais beaucoup sur le walk on en parle
beaucoup depuis maintenant quelques mois
moi je trouve que c'est assez révélateur
de ce qu'on risque de voir pendant
l'année prochaine à l'assemblée
nationale que l'identité de québec
solidaire elle est claire ils savent où
ils s'en vont les ont des thèmes forts
on peut les aimer ou ne pas les aimer
pour reprendre les mots du tireur de
délai me disait de gens qui est ici on
peut aimer ou non discours mais ce
discours là il est clair et je n'ai rien
à d'autres bois et un parlementaire
assez habile et ce type de
confrontations là ça fait son affaire
parce qu'il ya des gens qui sont pas
d'accord avec françois legault et la
manière dont il sait y est gérée la
campagne électorale fédérale
parce que bon on ressentait un
référendum sur la souveraineté du québec
solidaire honnêtement je pense que soit
le groupe ou ses bouchons peut-être un
peu loin mais ça va être un débat
intéressant un choc d'idées assez
intéressant québec solidaire et la
cohésion avec québec à la prochaine les
identités de chacun sont claires ou et
christian est intéressant
c'est un tournant c'est comme s'ils se
sont reconnus l'un des lots comme et
demi comme principal adversaire moi je
pense que le parti libéral est en panne
comme le parti québécois c'est pour la
retrouver dans la nature elle qui s'en
vient série jane le nouveau parti
conservateur qui marient le seul parti
qui montre aussi c'est le seul qui
contestent la gestion de la pandémie par
françois legault et autant il y aura
l'iman très imposant au tour de françois
legault il ya des gens qui n'étaient pas
d'accord il à éric duhaime et un
boulevard politique sait capable de
l'utiliser je pense sûr qu'il va être
capable et il ya aussi que gabriel
nadeau dubois qui réduit table je crois
que québec solidaire et redoutable c'est
très impressionnant la confrontation
c'est après cet après midi comme tel et
quand on dit vous êtes le moment rien il
faut prendre aussi il y avait le mot
angers en 10e contre pas dire plus il
est sorti du plessis la comparaison
monsieur francois louw avec dupuy
suspension comme pour le québécois
moynier on a le souvenir aussi précis de
duplessis mais voyons la taxe ne
cessa et quant à monsieur monsieur
legault aussi ne laisse pas grand doute
un beach culture waouh moi je vois
beaucoup plus péjoratif comme titulaire
mais je trouve ça devient très malsain
évoqué ce mais moi ce que je retiens
quand même à cause de leurs que gabriel
dubois faites attention parce qu'il me
semble ça risque de devenir ou leur
principal opposant oui c'était moi la
défense des des compétences compétentes
québécois j'en ai rien à cirer où ça
m'intéresse pas beaucoup je pense pas
qu'ils puissent faire beaucoup de chemin
avec ce genre d'union mais cela dit il
ya quelque chose qui est arrivé
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on est on entre
dans autre chose et les libéraux avec
entre autres le dérapage monsieur ben
harper hier puis
le saint père nous verrons
christian disent quelque chose
d'intéressant cathy se sont reconnus et
je pense que quand même de ce je pense
que les deux ont fait mouche là on à
partir du plessis l'autre ou qu ils ont
bien identifié ce que chacun a incarné à
sa manière et oui je pense que on a
raison de dire que sa demande quels sont
les deux grands une grande tendance
désormais les partis centristes qui
traditionnellement était un homme le
gamme de plusieurs courants plus un peu
plus à gauche un peu plus à droite sont
en perte de vitesse et donc oui c'est
cette dichotomie entre la turquie et le
québec solitaire ça ça vient un peu dans
la sphère politique n'est confirmé cette
polarisation à laquelle on assiste dans
la société qui se traduit dans le monde
politique alors oui c'est quand même
assez intéressant de voir ce
différences très marquées entre les deux
est évidemment bon monsieur
avec québec solidaire quand il dit moins
les compétences ça m'intéresse pas
évidemment il est exactement dans le
même discours qu'à ottawa le npd le
parti vert ou dix gardes si un problème
on s'emmêle et on s'en fout d'eux si la
responsabilité de qui cultive un juge
indépendant t sauf que en attendant s'il
faut partager ceci cela on fera pas deux
on deviendra pas fou allez-vous une
alarme et que l'on sait est chaque fois
buteur qui m'amène
débat là c'est que je sais que je pense
que c'est mon micro ondes qui vient
d'arriver ce sont ces
deux prochains débats à québec le débat
des chefs à québec ça va être quelque
chose avec ces deux là entre autres
merci beaucoup à vous trois bonne fin de
soirée
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici r d
oh